kate you know i gotta ask you about
knives out too we've been very attracted
to these lately what can you tell us you
know what nothing
you thought that you could control me
i don't know what you're talking about
you have to be honest with me why did
you even want me involved with this case
i'm so happy to be talking to you both
um it's so incredible to see a
female-led show that is so deliciously
mysterious kate i want to start with you
your first major tv role what about
truth be told made you say yes well she
would be sitting next to me but now it's
more virtual
i mean you know it starts with octavia
obviously executive producer star truth
be told and i'm just a a massive fan
and
you know you get to a certain point in
your career where you're like i just
want to work with great people and i
either want to work on something i'm
really passionate about like little
teeny things that maybe you're building
and then if something comes your way you
want it to be with people that you
admire and that you trust and that you
love and so when i heard about this and
i had the opportunity i was very excited
to jump on board and then of course i
read it you know and micah is such a fun
character to play my name is poppy
parnell and i will not give up until i
have
the truth so did you guys know each
other before this it sounds like you did
no no she just gave you quite a rave
review
well here's the thing it's so funny
because i've always been a fan of kate's
i mean when she burst on the scene she
burst on the scene and has been doing
this like since she was a kid so it's
hard not to know and love her but we
just really hit it off chemistry is not
something that you can fabricate and i
just respect her as an actress and we
had so much fun getting to know each
other and really unpacking these
characters together that i think you
know it becomes a once-in-a-lifetime
thing to be on a set surrounded by
people that you respect and with
material that you love and i'm really
holding this very close to my heart
because i i feel grateful during a
pandemic no less i mean no you know here
we were at the center of like the height
of california lockdown
um and covered numbers and it was it was
scary you know and people were
you know as as we everyone knowing
somebody who's suffering it created a
a very tight
family micah gonna do the podcast force
the police to look deeper into the case
i won't only find out what you want me
to know erito octavia i gotta ask if
you'd welcome another person uh into the
family of this cast she's already an ep
reese witherspoon could we get her on a
season three could we do a morning show
crossover some kind of cameo for reese i
thought reese was just about to pop up
i'm like oh my god
i thought you were about to be like
henry i know i'm like what reese can
come on anytime but i her her plate's
pretty full with morning show and i'm a
huge fan of a morning show and so many
of apple's original shows but listen
talk about you know people that that i
admire and all of the stuff that she's
doing in this space to create work for
women and opportunities for women
absolutely rhys come on anytime you like
kate you know i gotta ask you about
another casual little murder mystery
you're filming the answer is not so
simple knives out too you've been very
attracted to these lately what can you
tell us you know what nothing what about
your character what can you tell us
about your character or even just what
it's been like to film with this
cast
nothing
all i can say is i feel very honored to
be a part of it and
and everybody's absolutely wonderful are
you the killer
i'm the killer
it is not a donut hole but a smaller
donut with its own hole and our donut
is not whole at all
you seem to have brought the whole
family to greece and your photos are
incredible that video of you and your
daughter ronnie in the ocean i really
was moved watching it truly you said it
when you were sending a much-needed mom
hug out there to anybody how much has
she lit up your world and what do those
moments mean to you because it seems
like she's just this little light in
your family it's just endless i mean you
know i i she's really special she just
brought a completely different dynamic
to our family and she's just this
loving
funny she's hilarious oh my god and she
likes to be funny you know she's goofy i
think that when you get older and you've
had kids you know i got said almost 18
and two and a half
that you kind of soak in those moments a
little bit a little bit more and it's
those moments that i
just cherish well i was in the water
there i really did i felt like there was
this sort of serene kind of womb-like
safe connection that was happening and i
thought god if you could bottle that
feeling and just give it to the world it
might be a very very very different
place i love that she's funny do you
have some future actors or actresses
amongst your kids you think continue a
family tradition oh man i i hate to say
yes but i'm gonna say yes especially
ryder and bing is such a like a numbers
guy and he's got stocks he's really into
stocks a financier okay
yeah he he loves trading stocks that's
what he wanted for his birthday
uh he's 10.
so i was saying by the time he's 12
he'll be handling my portfolio but uh
tavia i i
i gotta ask you real quick i love you
know when your credits come up it's
academy award winner octavia spencer and
um ten years this year since the help
came out
i told god i'd never speak of it again
what makes that film still special for
you and do you keep in touch with the
cast
absolutely i keep in touch with the cast
i
feel very fortunate that i
got to
work with my close friends and and tate
and brunson and allison janney and then
i got to play this amazing character who
wouldn't feel blessed and here we are
it's come full circle 10 years later i'm
getting to work with amazing cast and
with a character that i i love so i'm
lucky there's a moment in the show where
your character sees herself on a
billboard and it's kind of a moment and
i was wondering if either of you have a
moment that comes to mind for when you
knew okay i've made it i'm here this is
big oh i've never had that moment i
don't think you ever get comfortable
you're always like oh i can't believe i
can't believe it
but i do remember a moment once and it
was almost famous poster because that
was really like my face
and that was pretty cool and here you
are getting to pick who you work with
like this woman what about you octavia
honey the first time somebody paid me to
act was i knew i'd made it and then
you're like oh they they can pay you
more so hey you know my very first
paycheck as a sandra bullock's nurse and
a time to kill with one line i felt like
i had made it i had come a long way baby
i and i had further to go so here we are
here we are you want to know some crazy
trivia
yes staying in the chorus of home alone
you know i sang when i was little and
they had this opening to sing in a movie
and it ended up being home alone and i
still will get like a dollar fifty
residual checks from home alone that's
amazing like the christmas course with
the kids and the kids chorus yeah it was
kind of wild i got it through my chorus
that i was singing with and but isn't
that i mean i felt i i felt the same way
which i got that little jack i was like
oh this is awesome awesome
oh my gosh well kate we know you have a
voice i'm ready for you to sing in a
project again it knives out too
can you give me one word for what
filming is like oh this is so funny no i
there's nothing to say there's nothing
to say